觉得你现在首要需要解决的问题啊，
不是说跟这个男人的关系的问题，
首要解决的问题是你自己的生存的问题，
你要生存的话，
你首先要有一个好的身体，
你要有一个健康的身体，
得自己去想办法，
没有人会对我的身体负责任的，
没有人会24小时盯着我身体好不好的，
只有我自己会对我自己的身体负责任。
我今年30岁，
我老公34，
我俩结婚四年了，
因为他家里条件不好嘛，
我当时彩礼就是8万，
但这个彩礼呢，
是他父母借的，
我们婚后我老公自己的工资还的8000块钱，
就给我买了个戒指相链，
他买了个戒指，
包括婚礼的话，
也是我们自己借钱拿后那个礼钱去还的，
我自己也出了钱，
这就是一个基本情况吧，
当时对我也特别好，
所以我家人就说，
嗯，
你们两个自己努力的话，
过两三年日子也能好起来，
他就结婚了嘛。
今年是8月份，
我们俩就有一次闹离婚了，
原因是我追星，
但是他婚前也知道我追星，
他就说是他能帮我抢票，
也希望我去看，
但是婚后的话，
我提前自己的工资，
我去看了之后他就跟我闹离婚，
他说我价值观有问题，
他把我的朋友圈截图，
想要给我爸爸打电话追星说话，
我自己的钱没花他的钱。
去不去，
先别那个啥，
当时他说离婚我觉得也可以，
我说又没花你的钱，
如果你要是因为这个离婚的话，
那姑也同意，
因为你当时那么穷，
我也嫁给你，
我就不是图你的钱，
我就是图你的人，
他不同意，
因为我俩现在是异地，
那经上我又去了他那边，
就又和好了，
中间还有一些事情，
我俩是二二年办的婚礼，
结的婚，
因为他是在工程上，
婚后在异地的话，
可能感情也就会不太好吧，
因为两人就是聚少离多，
我就过去了，
去他那边，
结果二三年的时候就意外怀孕了，
我们俩婚前说的是先不要孩子，
但是怀孕之后我第一反应已也挺高兴的，
因为毕竟当时感情也好，
但我老公的反应就是不想要，
好愁啊，
你怎么还有孩子呢？
然后我说那你不想要的话，
咱就不要这孩子了，
我孕反很严重，
然后吃不了东西，
闻不了各种东西，
让他也封床水，
我多难受他都不管我就因为这件事我也跟我家人说，
我说我不想要这孩子，
我也不想跟他在一块儿，
我想离婚了，
当时都请了律师了，
这个孩子就没要，
没要之后呢，
他因为我又很好，
一直到现在的话，
就今年一个演唱会，
这个事情是最严重，
现在的话我就觉得跟这个人你说凑合日子过吧，
好像也能过，
但是很多事你就指望不上他，
他也不会给你撑。
爸他家里情况也不好，
他爸妈也从来也不咋管他，
他爸妈身体也不好，
现在就是也没有什么基本劳动力，
就是靠儿女每个月看病啊啥的，
只问他要钱的时候会给他打电话，
不要钱的话候你不打电话，
这个我就很生气，
我说你家人都不管你，
我说你好歹就是你给了钱，
你自己记个账，
因为他还有个哥，
我不是说不让你给爸妈看病，
看病我也会经常去看，
也会花钱，
但是他们就感觉不到你对他的这种好，
那为我现在在想，
这个还有必要继续下去嘛。
然还再有一个就是我们家人也开始让我俩生孩子，
说不生孩子怎么样，
你们两口子有存款吗？
他现在有10个，
还有外债吗？
我外债应该没有，
当时娶你的时候，
8万的彩礼是谁还的，
我老公还了，
你老公一个月挣多少钱，
当时可能就六七七千分，
还有1万多，
你挣多少钱一个月我正常上班的话能有5000，
那你现在不正常上班吗？
我现在辞职了，
为啥辞职啊，
我因为身体也不好，
就是从今年七月份到现在，
就是那个生理期也不正常，
基本上绝经了一样那种，
就休息一下，
想调理一下身体，
那你自己有存款吗？
有，
但是我这个不算从。
话说在我下一份工作之前，
我能把自己维持住，
那给的那8万彩礼在谁手里啊？
我给我爸妈了，
你还有兄弟姊妹吗？
所以我哥假设将来生了孩子，
谁能帮你带孩子啊？
公婆的话他带不了，
所以我不想生孩子，
追一次星住宿包括演唱会的门票，
包括路费，
追一次星大概要花多少钱？
也就3000左右。
好，
那你现在想要问过我的问题是什么呢？
我就是想从旁观者，
您这个角度的话，
就是我不生孩子，
给我点建议吧，
你以后都不打算生孩子了吗？
我不想生，
如果你自己打定了主意不想要孩子，
那么咱们就应该摊在桌面上来讲，
把决定权交给人家对方，
如果人家对方结婚的目的是要组建家庭，
是要生孩子的话，
人家好趁年轻有的选，
就如果说你确定你想好了，
你这辈子你不想要孩子，
咱不能欺瞒对方，
不能让别人抱着一个假期望跟我过这个日子，
这不道德，
是不是我跟他说过啊，
你跟他说过，
那他是什么态度呢？
刚开始他也同意，
他说不生就不生，
我们现在自己也过不好，
就先不生，
但是他现在又让我生，
现在在生孩子这件事情上产生了矛盾呢，
那你要问龙。
所以我的观点是，
我觉得你现在这个条件，
以你现在这个状态的话，
不生才是对的，
为什么你生完了之后也没有人帮你带呀？
以你现在的这种精神状态，
坦率的说，
你觉得你是会是一个有能量保护好一个幼小生命，
有力量、
有担当，
有责任心的好母亲吗？
你心智成熟了吗？
你自己的人生安排明白了吗？
我知道，
其实每个人有自己的追求，
这都很正常啊，
自己挣钱自己花，
想干什么干什么，
这个都是年轻人理想的状态。
但是你要知道，
你一个月挣5000块钱，
你一个月能攒下来多少钱，
你能攒下来2000就不错了，
对不对？
钱是要花在刀刃上的，
花在什么叫刀刃上？
你身体健康吗？
你该不该调理一下身体，
该不该自己吃点好的，
补点好的，
身体都不健康，
一天天的都是跑，
费什么心看什么演唱会，
对不起啊，
我菲姐可能是有点老太太心态，
管的有点多了啊，
就你能听进去，
你就这么一听，
你要是听不进去，
就当我放屁，
就当你自己一个月就这5000块钱的时候，
你的钱要用来干什么，
要用来保证我是身体健康的，
我该吃点啥，
我该补点啥，
我该调理点啥，
我缺点啥，
看看中医我怎么调节一下，
我要钱是要用来干这个的，
我知道，
所以我就是想说出来，
你帮我看看，
但是我看评论区那个。
花钱我追10年，
我就见了这一次花了3000块钱，
然后评果区直边说干工作干了多少年呀，
我毕业到现在的话，
10年我能上8年班吧，
上8年班你攒了多少钱呀，
我挺能攒钱，
攒到一个数额之后就花花花，
所以到现在没攒下钱，
我会给家里人花的比较多，
那家里人你结婚的时候给你嫁妆了吗？
给了给了多少嫁妆啊，
我没要钱，
没嫁的，
相当于装修之后的家电这些，
所以没有钱，
你想问我啥问题吧，
其实我现在在想就是跟我老公谈一次，
就是问他如果说不生孩子的话，
他要是能过的话，
我还要继续过嘛，
结婚四年了，
就是习惯了，
你要说生吧，
可能会有点难受，
我觉得你现在首要需要解决的问题啊，
不是说跟这个男人的关系的问题，
首要解决的问题是你自己的生存的问题，
你要生存的话，
你首先要有一个好的身体，
你要有一个健康的身体，
得自己去想办法，
没有人会对我的身体负责任的，
没有人会24小时盯着我身体好不好的，
只有我自己会对我自己的身体负责任，
如果我现在月经不正常了，
都已经停经了，
我是不是得去医院查一下为什么原因导致的，
查一下我的卵巢功能，
查一下我的AMH值，
查一下我的生育能力，
查一下我自己对为什么会导致我停经，
我是不是得去导。
这个我应该把这个事情是不是放在第一位，
我说句功利一点的话，
如果现在这个男人的存在可以让我静下心来养身体的话，
那么他存在对于我是有价值的，
我那么着急跟他撇清关系干什么？
如果说这个男人的存在导致我身心不健康，
导致我抑郁，
那我可能会让这个男人在我剧本里面刷新，
搞身体，
身体搞得差不多了，
工作上班，
自己有生存的能力了，
能养活自己了，
再来考虑一下我追求的是什么，
做好避孕措施啊，
好，
那就这样哈，
拜拜，
要是实在没钱的话，
你说你彩礼钱也给爸妈了，
你这些年挣的钱也给家里了，
实在没钱，
你是不是也可以问家里人要点钱，
说我要看病啊，
这也是一个检验，
检验一下他们到底是只进不出，
他们对你到底有没有爱，
对你到底有没有关心，
如果这一次检验他们没钱给你一毛不拔，
你说你都要去医院看病了，
没钱了，
他都五千八千的，
三万2万的都不给你，
那你你以后你挣了钱，
你还愿意给他们吗？
记得点赞关注哦。